[Music]
[Applause]
hold
on we've got Troopers up
[Music]
top we're running out of
road that exactly a stealth exit boys
let's
move I thought that the end of the war
would mean an end to losing more of our
brothers I was
wrong we can't just walk away not with
the Empire imprisoning of the
kid secure her in a
Cell omega's been waiting for us a long
time our
mission is not over
yet there is nothing of Greater
importance to to secure the future of
this
Empire whatever is needed to accomplish
goal you will have
it they are
coming for all of
you give us a real
challenge
everyone down we're not big on following
orders I wasn't planning on killing you
but you're making it very
tempting
[Music]